[Music]  none of us really know each other but we  were all in the same place when Billy  found those points I guess - what's  wrong  the same is true the answer to what is  happening to you is here you five are  the Power Rangers any other questions  a little more like Iron Man Oh  spider-man could you just say something  anything  me and four kids found a spaceship  buried underground whoa  pretty sure my superhero what caused  five little Ranger  okay that's cool let's go  Power Rangers Power Rangers lady pg-13  in theaters March 24th me and four kids  found a spaceship buried underground huh  I'm pretty sure I'm a superhero  cool ping in that Cup Oh